you think about writing a quadratic in
vertex form this is the form that we're
after here y equals a times X minus H
the quantity squared plus K and our
vertex is H comma K okay so you can see
the h and the K right there that's the
vertex point now the form that they're
giving us the quadratic in here
is actually the y equals ax squared plus
BX plus C or like a general form of the
quadratic and so what we need to do here
is we need to go from this form to this
form now the easier method that I'm
going to show you here is that we're
going to use this formula x equals
negative B over 2a to find the
x-coordinate of the vertex
and then what we're going to do is are
going to put it back into the equation
to find the y-coordinate so let's go
ahead and do that so negative B over 2a
that's going to be the opposite of
negative 4 which is positive 4 over 2
times a which is 2 and you can see we're
getting 4 over 4 which equals 1 so
that's the x-coordinate of the vertex
now if we put one back in for X we get 2
times 1 squared minus 4 times 1 plus 1
and if we simplify that we get 2 minus 4
plus 1 which is let's see negative 1 so
you can see that our vertex is at 1
negative 1 so if we go back to our
vertex form over here we can see that a
is 2 okay so we're going to put 2 in
here so we've got y equals 2x minus 1
okay there's our H squared minus 1 now
the thing to pay attention to is is that
this value right here is going to be the
opposite okay so see how this was
positive 1 but we have X is minus 1 it's
going to have the opposite sign okay so
that's something